foreign
let's go out to Michigan to the great
city of Lansing and talk to Brother John
what's up John with the greatest name
ever how we doing good how are you doing
thanks for having me you got it man
thanks for thanks for uh giving me a
buzz what's up
so I'm uh 26 years old and I'm just
wondering how do I navigate my
relationship with my parents who are in
the process of separating oh man what
happened
well I mean I'll try to give you the
story let me know if I start to Ramble
On too much but essentially my parents
have been married about 30 years
um and there's some things I don't know
all the details of because you know I
was a kid when a lot of this happened
but I guess about 20 years ago
um there was an issue where my mom had
made some untrue statements about you
know some domestic situation it had gone
to court we I remembered living separate
you know with my mom away from my dad
for a time then they got back together
after things kind of settled
um and my mom had apologized to my dad
about it but hasn't ever really made
kind of like a I guess my dad hasn't
felt like she's made a kind of a public
acknowledgment that he isn't you know
this monster or this person who she had
said that he was and there's just been
issues kind of stemming from that where
he's never gotten over that past hurt
um and she's kind of you know just kind
of put it behind her as oh you know I
apologize to you like it's done and then
things kind of basically surfaced you
know again this past fall
um
and my mom ended up kind of leaving the
house in December around the time of her
birthday when she would usually go on a
trip down south to stay with her stepmom
down there
um but she ended up staying down there
for like 12 weeks
um and part of it was she was saying
that she was helping you know uh this
relative move because they're in the
process of moving they're a little bit
elderly
um but the whole time you know she was
saying oh you know your dad he told me
that I had to leave the house
um and then I'm not welcome back where
you know then I passed my dad he's like
no you know I miss her I wanted to come
home like I can't get a hold of her
um and then finally she moved back into
you know move back to the to Michigan
um in like March but ended up moving
into
um a condo with a relative of hers that
was sick
let me hop in here did she no you're
good man you're dude I'm the chief
Rambler man you can't touch me I'm the
goat at rambling so you're good
um I appreciate you you welcoming me
through that story quick point of
clarification
did your
mom accused your dad of some sort of
domestic violence again
or uh no has never happened again
this summer this fall
um
I think it was around the anniversary of
like when did it happen
so what what was the accusation
it seems to be a dark shadow over your
parents marriage
um it I don't it's hard for me to say
because it's like I've never heard them
both talk about it to me together where
it's like they're both speaking about it
together so it's hard to say because if
there could always be like a he said she
said but so um I'm assuming the courts
didn't put your dad in jail so I'm
assuming the court started with him
yeah
something along those lines where but
the the exact station was something
about either that he had beat her or had
done something to the kids or that it
wasn't a safe situation but that you
know that wasn't the case I have no
memory of any situation like that so as
as one of your parents actually filed on
the other one
no they haven't but it's like it's kind
of like it could be any moment they're
kind of you know yeah there could also
be another 20 years because they were
going to separate when she made all
these accusations against him and he
stuck it out
so here's here's what you've got and I
hate to do this not in person because
um it can be pretty callous okay is it
cool if I just didn't just kind of cut
to the chase
yeah go ahead okay
um it sounds like
and again I know there's always two
sides to every story right but it sounds
like your mom did something
that was pretty awful to your old man
back in the day
and maybe it was 80 20 maybe it was 90
10. but then it sounds like your dad has
acted like a four-year-old for the last
20 years or last 15 years of
not wanting to move on not able to move
on and when I say move on not just
forgive and forget that's what I'm
talking about I'm talking about if
you're gonna if you're out of your
marriage leave your marriage
um give your yourself and your family
opportunity to heal or if you're all in
you got to be all in back in it just
seems like both of your parents this has
just been a weird dynamic and so I I I I
have no evidence from the story you've
just laid out that they're actually
going to get divorced
sounds like yet another move that
somebody's putting on somebody or
somebody and maybe they will maybe get
divorced tomorrow
um I've got a couple so so I say all
that what's your response to that
um
I I've definitely seen that because I
know back you know my dad used to say
that he was gonna that they were gonna
probably separate once you know my
little sister like went to college when
she was out of the house and then that
didn't happen but I guess what what
recently developed is when she came back
into the area but still is not moving
into the house that relative that she
was helping take care of ended up
passing and now my mom's trying to buy
her condo from my cousin to then live in
this new condo and that that's what's
making me think that it's like it's
become she's been practicing living on
her own for the last three or four or
five months
yeah okay
um have you sat down individually with
each parent and talked to him
um I've been able to talk with him on
the phone individually
um
and I guess what's hard is you know my
mom is you know I love her and she's
great but she can just be kind of a
manipulative and emotional and like if
you try to you know give your honest
opinion of like hey you know this isn't
the right move like I don't think you
should you know be taking out a mortgage
to buy this condo it's not you know it's
not you know you're acting you know a
little bit too you know irrationally you
know she you know she can't take that
feedback It all becomes a personal
attack of like is she asking for that
feedback
what was that is she asking for that
yes and no okay because the other day
you know because my my another kind of
dynamic is my wife works for her she
owns like a small business oh geez
um and then that's a you know there's a
blurred boundary there of you know
family versus employer
um yeah it's definitely Robin Thicke
Blurred lives there brother
yeah and she calls my wife you know kind
of upset almost crying saying you know I
feel like you know people are talking
behind my back but they won't just tell
me you know they are of course they're
thinking all right so I'm gonna jump in
here here's yeah go ahead
you're gonna have to grow up real quick
okay
and so I'm gonna rattle some of these
off if one or two of them just sounds
stupid or doesn't make sense or might
not work in your family push back okay
step number one your wife's gonna have
to get a new job
Point Blank period if you want to keep
your marriage intact you want to have
some sort of relationship with your mom
Downstream she's gonna have to decide to
get a new job and I absolutely
understand the complexity of what that
will look like both interpersonally and
professionally all that
number two you are gonna have to make
space in your soul
to be surprised by how sad you are
if they the divorce actually goes
through
especially young adults you know 20 to
I can't tell you how many I've sat with
who are just stunned by how sad they are
their parents split up like they're
grown-ups they got their own family
their own house
but there was always this anchor they
were anchored into even if their parents
marriage was a disaster
there's always this this tiny little
fairy of a of a uh fantasy that things
are going to work themselves back out
and there's a finality too I just bought
a house I divorce you and as a kid no
matter how old you are it's a
it's an unmooring thing the floor kind
of comes out from underneath you so I
want you to be expecting that don't
fight it don't run from it but when you
get real sad be real sad that's okay
that's not nothing to be ashamed of
you're not broken you're not weird
I would if I were you so I'm just all
I'm doing is projecting myself into your
situation 26 I'm married my wife works
for my mom I've also been talking to my
dad on the phone I would set aside a
weekend and I would go visit each parent
individually and what here's what I
would do I would lay out my
participation in this moving forward
here's what that means dad mom says
she's buying a house that y'all looks
like y'all are moving on I here's gonna
be my role in this I'm gonna love you
you're my dad and I'm gonna love her
she's my mom I'm not picking sides
and I'm gonna cut off any conversation
that gets negative about the other
parent I'm just not going to participate
in that
and I want you to spend some time with
you and your wife coming up with
whatever those boundaries are gonna be
the more you can get on the front end of
that and let everybody know yourself
included what you will and will not do
um the better off you're gonna be able
to find out where they are and the
better off you're going to be as this
thing unravels and gets messy and silly
so there's something about just saying
hey this is gonna I'm gonna cut off
negative talk and your impulse is going
to be to rescue your mom rescue your dad
you can't be their best friend you can't
be their therapist you can't be their
Pastor doing all this mess you can say I
love you have you called your friends
I love you so much I hate that you're
you're hurting like this
um have you gone to see a counselor but
you can't be their person as hard as
that is okay and then here's the last
one
I want you and no second to last one I
want you and your wife to preemptively
Imagine Holidays
preemptively imagine birthdays
and I want you all to come up with a set
of ground rules that you will dictate to
your parents not the other way around
because all of this you get you get
divorced in September it becomes
finalized at Christmas
Mom and Dad have very clear pictures in
the head of what Christmas is going to
look like and both you and your wife are
involved in both of those pictures
and that's not going to be possible
and so I want you all to preemptively
have that discussion and it will break
your heart to do it it'll feel it will
feel surreal
but I want you and your wife to say okay
this is what Thanksgiving will look like
for us and Mom and Dad chose to separate
they chose to to be by themselves on the
holidays it's not our job to fix that
loneliness but here's what we can do
we can do the morning here in the
afternoon here we can just pick one this
year and the next year we'll pick one
because they chose to separate not us
it's not your job to make their holiday
fantasies come true and their birthday
fantasies and when y'all start having
kids all
guys we're having one birthday party
y'all can both be adults and come to or
y'all can decide amongst yourself who's
coming or not we're not going to play
dad's house in Mom's house and Grandma's
I'm not gonna do that whatever you all
decide to do okay here's the last thing
tell your mom and dad that you love them
every single time you talk to them
every time even if you're pissed off and
you're mad and you think they act like
children tell them you love them every
step of the way because you're going to
need some sort of tether back to family
in reality all right I just do a ton at
you what do you think
um I mean
that is a lot but I think there's a lot
of good things to pull from that and I
think you know establishing boundaries
is going to be really important I guess
my one last thing regarding that is just
I feel like I so badly want to try to
help don't don't don't counselors give
feedback when they're asking for
feedback nope nope nope nope nope
um because they're going to drag you
into the nerd word is they're going to
triangulate you they're gonna you're
gonna become the fulcrum of their
relationship
because you're the oldest boy you're the
26 year old you've been helping in your
your quote unquote making it and weirdly
they mom gave your wife a job you owe us
to that's why I say your wife's gotta
gotta decouple from that she's gotta
she's got to go a different route
you have to withdraw from some of that
entanglement so that you can put up
clear boundaries and not have those
things held over your head
you're gonna get dragged into it and
that's why I said You're Gonna Wanna
rescue your mom and your dad from the
choices they have made and you can't do
it
can't do it what does that sound like in
real life
honey I'm so your mom calls you and
she's crying I can't believe your dad
did this did this
um
I'm so so sorry that you're heartbroken
it breaks my heart
I'm not going to talk about Dad on this
phone call I've already talked to you
about that not gonna talk about Dad
but I will tell you I love you and I'm
so so sorry that you're heartbroken have
you called so and so and you fill in the
blank
and that's going to be you putting up
really firm strong boundaries because
you can't rescue them out of this
is that gonna be hard for you
it'd be hard for me it'd be real hard
for me yeah it's going to be hard
especially because it's going to be an
adjustment because I feel like I've been
someone who likes to I mean I'm someone
who likes to give counsel and advice and
say Hey you know this isn't you know the
smartest decision right now or hey can
you you know can I tell you can I tell
you what my guess is my guess is you've
been parenting both of them for most of
your life
and my guess is you have been the voice
of reason for them for most of your life
and my promise to you is that is not
your job
and unfortunately it never has been
let me rephrase that it has been your
whole life unfortunately it should not
have been
and so the problem with divorce is it's
not never it's never between just two
people it ricochets through a family it
ricochets through a family system
and the Dynamics that have existed for 5
10 15 20 30 years like in your case even
unhealthy ones everything is blown up
and so everyone around this situation
even when it divorces Justified and it's
a right and it's the right thing it's
still painful to everybody
and there's family systems that have to
create new Dynamics and new avenues and
New Paths out in the woods because man
it's just different now things are
different
so yeah you've been the fixer and the
helper and the parent quite honestly
probably for your whole life
and you're gonna have to find esteem in
other places so instead of solving every
problem with a magic wand or breaking
your own back to solve their problems
you're gonna have to shift to I can't
solve this one y'all chose this but I'll
sit with you and I love you not going to
talk about mom not going to talk about
Dad not going to give you advice and
wisdom but I love you and I'm grateful
for you
thank you so much for the call Brother
John holler back if I can help in any
way